Greetings, and welcome to today's webinar,
a new way to prepare genome submissions for
GenBank.
My name is Colleen Bollin.
In addition to being the technical program
manager now , in the past I previously worked
on the development team for Sequin , and later
the development team for Genome Workbench.
Today I will be demonstrating how to use the
editing package in Genome Workbench to prepare
genome submissions for a single organism in
GenBank.
So, what is Genome Workbench?
It is a GUI application that runs on Windows,
Linux, MacOS.
And provides a rich set of tools for creating
and viewing phylogenetic trees, alignments,
tabular data and more.
You can use it with public data from NCBI
or elsewhere or with your own private data
. You can also use it to prepare your own
data for submission to GenBank.
Peter is going to launch a poll questions.
If you can take a minute to answer that.
Okay, so everybody should be seeing this polling
question.
It is how familiar are you with Genome Workbench.
Go ahead and select all of the ones that apply.
I will go ahead and close that polling question
now.
And you should be seeing the results.
So, a wide distribution of experience here.
Some of you have never heard of it.
Many of you have heard of it but have never
used it.
Some others have some experience with it.
That is a wide distribution of experience
with this.
I will hide it, and we should be able to see
your sides again.
Okay, great.
As I mentioned before, we have a slide for
how you can download your own copy of Genome
Workbench.
https://www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/tools/gbench/downloads/
So, follow the instructions on the side.
Please do check out our website for manuals
and tutorials.
We have lots.
Our customer outreach people are mad at me
because I am using the tiny font size just
to get the tutorials, not even the manuals,
all on one page.
There is lots of good stuff.
We have a YouTube channel.
Lots to learn there.
Genome Workbench has many valuable tools for
modifying your submission and doing other
kinds of analysis , and we won't be able to
cover all of them today.
These are some of the ones from editing that
we won't get to today, but they are documented
on the website that I just mentioned, and
in the tutorials and manuals.
So, I am going to switch over to the live
demo.
The first thing we need to do when you first
download Genome Workbench, you need to enable
the editing package.
To do that, you launch Genome Workbench , and
you go to the tools menu.
You select packages.
You pick the sequence editing package.
You click enable, and you click okay.
It is going to say changes will take effect
when you restart Genome Workbench, so let's
do that now.
Peter, while we are waiting for Genome Workbench
to start up, could you start the second polling
question?
Yes I will do that.
Let me see.
Okay.
Okay, I will launch the pole.
The question here is, which tools have you
used to prepare submissions to GenBank . Please
answer.
We will let that run for maybe 30 seconds
to give everybody a chance to vote.
And you know, one of the options here is other.
If you are using something else, I don't know
what that might be, but you can put that in
the questions pod if you want.
Okay, let's give it about 5 more seconds.
Okay.
I am going to close the poll now.
I am sharing it.
I see a lot of fans of Sequin.
Sequin is the biggest one there . Then BankIt
then tbl2asn.
Some people have used Genome Workbench before
to do this and then there are some others
in there as well.
Great.
So now we are back in Genome Workbench and
one of the things you should notice that is
different is that we now have a submission
menu.
That was not there before because we had not
enabled the editing package.
At the top of the submission menu is the Genome
Submission Wizard.
Because I did not have a sequence record open,
it is prompting me to open one now.
If I already had one open, it would use the
one I already had open.
If I already had one open, it would use that.
I am just going to choose this file here.
For the purposes of this demonstration, I
am going to use a draft version of a whole
genome shotgun submission that was prepared
using tbl2asn a commandline tool available
on the NCBI ftp site that many of you are
already familiar with.
I could also have used a file that was prepared
by NCBI's prokaryotic genome annotation pipeline,
also known as PGAP, or with other tools that
generate valid ASN 1.
Or I could have used a file with FASTA sequences.
So, now that I have the file opened, you will
notice two things.
The first is that the wizard has pulled in
the submitter name and email address that
I provided in the ASN 1 file.
We are going to see the other information
already in the file as we go through the other
tabs.
The wizard will prompt me for required information
that could not get out of the file that we
imported.
The second thing you should notice is that
the wizard automatically opened up a Flat
File View of my sequences.
I get a preview of how my sequences would
look on the GenBank website.
The information in the flat file will be updated
as I move between tabs and I make changes.
Note that this is different from Sequin , and
that with Sequin you always had to start with
FASTA files and then enter the data manually
or import a template.
You can still import and export templates
from the wizard at any time using the import
from template button here on the bottom or
the export to template button on the right.
That should be familiar to you, hopefully.
So, here we have the affiliation sub tab and
you can see the asterisks to tell you which
fields are required.
You can also see the information that was
imported from my ASN 1 file.
You should also notice is back and continue
buttons at the bottom left and bottom right
of the dialogue.
You can use those to move through the tabs,
or you can skip around using the tab controls
up at the top.
So, on the General tab, I can enter the bioproject
and biosample IDs and indicate when the data
will be made public.
You do not need to add IDs here because you
will have an opportunity to enter them when
you upload the file to the submission portal.
You do need to preregister a bioproject and
a biosample if you are submitting with annotation,
but otherwise the portal will help you create
those at the time that you upload your file.
You can create bioproject and BioSample successions
in the pages . And Internet search for submission
BioProject will also find the correct page
for you.
Moving on, we have assembly and sequence information.
You have the option of providing the assembly
and sequencing information here, or in the
web forms where you submit your sequences
later.
If you provide them here, you can see how
they will look in the flat file, and you won't
have to reenter them.
Let's move on to the organism info pay.
Here this information was extracted from the
ASN 1 file that I imported.
I do not need to extract it again or worry
that it will not match what I already entered.
You can also see there are double asterisks
after strain, isolate, cultivar, and breed.
You need to provide information for at least
one of these fields.
On the additional qualifiers page, the strain
information that we found in the imported
file is also here.
You can use this page to add more information,
like the collection date, or correct information
that is already in the file.
You also have an opportunity to provide this
information when you create your BioProject
and BioSample accessions.
The data will be copied to your submission
during the upload process so you will not
need to do it twice.
This is a draft genome, so we do not have
individual sequences to represent the entire
chromosome or organelles.
In that case, we can leave these tabs blank
and move on to annotation.
So, the annotation tab.
I am really excited about this tab, because
it has some great new features that were not
in Sequin.
For example , the existing features that I
already created in my file are displayed here
using the NCBI five column feature table format.
I could also use this import from feature
table button at the upper left-hand corner
of the dialogue to import a file with more
features, and I can do that from the five
column feature table format, or GFF3.
We have had a lot of requests for GFF3 and
we are excited to be able to offer it to you
now.
I wanted to point out that some of the fields
that you see here, like translation table,
those were automatically calculated for you
when the annotation was imported.
You do not need to provide them yourself.
So, if you need more information about the
five column feature table, there is a link
to that in the notes for this slide deck.
Moving on, on the sequence authors tab, I
would list the name of the researchers responsible
for sequencing data.
Note that this list does not have to include
the contact person for the submission that
was on the first tab.
But it could.
Now, on the publication sub tab, I am going
to enter information about the publication
that is associated with the submission, including
the title or working title for unpublished
articles.
The publication authors and the sequence authors
can be different.
If you would like them to be the same, you
can select the same as sequence authors radio
button in the center of the dialogue.
File I was working with had different authors,
so the radio button was automatically set
to the other option which is specify new authors.
So, the validation tab has two sub tabs, validate
and submitter report.
These two tabs will show you the kinds of
errors and warnings that GenBank indexers
would look at when reviewing your submission.
So , if you can correct the problems ahead
of time, your submission can be processed
much faster.
Note that you do need to manually trigger
each of these reports after making changes
or coming to the tab for the first time.
Examining the record can take a minute or
two so we do not do it automatically after
each update.
For both of these reports, you can single
click on the item that the error or warning
refers to, and the submission wizard will
automatically scroll to the portion of the
flat file that shows that item.
If you double-click on the item, the editor
for that item will be launched.
We will show that later.
Four help interpreting and fixing problems,
there is a link to a help page in the note
for this slide deck.
I will validate the record.
So, a common problem that we see in submissions
is stop and protein.
That is the third errorstop and protein.
That is the third error that we see here.
There could be many reasons for this error.
One is that the wrong translation frame was
selected for the coding region.
If we single click on this error, you will
note that the flat file has automatically
scrolled to that feature.
We are looking at it and we can see, okay,
this coding region starts at the five prime
end of the sequence, so it is possible that
this is a partial coding region and we just
need to change the frame.
So, quickly right now, I would like to take
a look at the flat file.
You will see a pen and an X icon that you
can use, the pen will allow you to add a coding
region and the X will allow you to delete
the coding region.
These will only be visible when you have the
editing package enabled.
I can either use the pen icon to launch the
editor here or I can double-click on it from
the validator.
I'm going to double-click here and we will
launch the editor for the coding region.
So, in the editor, I can experiment with changing
the reading frame using this reading frame
control here, and then using the re-translate
button.
We will change it to two, and I see that I
still have stop codons in this translation
box.
Let's try changing it to three, and re-translating,
and look, we have a translation that has a
stop codon where the stop codon should be.
Excellent.
It is clearly meant to be frame three.
Now, I would like you to notice that I have
the Update Gene span box checked by default,
which means that if I make changes to the
location of the coding region, the gene location
will get changed at the same time so they
will stay this dame.
This is important because we also want to
mark this coding region as five prime partial.
To do that, we will click on the Location
in the left-hand panel and we will just check
the five prime box.
That is all.
Now we will click on okay to finish editing.
And you can see that the flat file is refreshing
itself.
Now I am going to validate the record again.
I could just move on to a different error
to work on something else before re-validating,
but sometimes when you make one change, it
actually fixes possible problems.
Let's just revalidate this record.
So, now I want to look at the last two validator
errors.
Terminal Ns, and the high N 5% prime.
They both refer to the same sequence.
You can see over here, in the sequence column,
and I can single click on it will navigate
to the contig003 sequence for me in the flat
file.
So, you have two ways to fix this kind of
an error.
One of those as you can go to the submissions,
sequences, trim terminal Ns menu item and
click on.
This will remove them from the 5 prime and
3 prime ends of all of your sequences, and
adjust the annotation automatically for you
so that the features still cover the same
nucleotides, and it will trim features that
overlap the Ns , and re-translate the coding
regions that were trimmed and give you a nice
report.
However, I want to show you a different way
to do this.
Am going to use the undo method over here
in the edit menu, and if you are familiar
with Sequin, you will remember that we had
no undo . This is a great thing we are really
excited about.
So instead I am going to go submission, sequences,
edit sequence, whips.
Here we go.
We are going to pick contig003.
Sometimes when you undo something that changes
the focus, but that just means have to go
back and select your sequence again.
Anyways, let's go to submission, sequences,
edit sequences, and here we see the sequence
editor.
So, this is also a nifty thing that I am really
proud of.
One of the things you can do with the sequence
editor is you can just use your mouse to drag
and highlight the nucleotides that you want
to delete, and then you can hit the delete
key, and they are gone.
They are not really gone until I hit the commit
button, which I will do now, so that I can
make other changes.
You could also use this to remove vector contamination
or low-quality sequence that you found using
some other tool.
Also, this is nice.
If you don't want to select a large sequence
with your mouse, or you want to be very precise
about which nucleotides you are selecting,
you can just type in the locations that you
want in the select box and click on select.
You will see that they are highlighted, which
is nifty.
One of the things you can do is you can use
the sequence editing dialog to add new features.
If you have selected a location, and then
you go to your features menu, and pull up
your feature, the location is going to be
your selection.
You can just, you can do it that way.
Another thing you can do with the sequence
editing tool is, here we can see the new feature
I just created, you can use the show menu
to display reading frames.
I can show all of my positive direction reading
frames, and I can also show the complement.
There are some other things that you can find
out about in the show menu.
Check out our manual.
It is really neat.
We are just going to close this, and now you
can see we have two misc features.
I'm going to go back to the submission wizard
just hanging out in the background that I'm
going to move on to the submitter report.
I will refresh that so we can get the results.
So, the submitter report shows problems with
the submission that might involve multiple
objects, or situations where it is unclear
which of multiple items is incorrect, or also
patterns that may or may not indicate a problem
with the record, but that we would like the
submitter to review.
For example, it is possible for two different
sequences to have some of the same metadata
values, but often it is an indication that
they made a mistake during data entry.
Here, let us take a look at this first item
in the report which says we have two genes
with duplicate locus tags.
Now, locus tags are required to be unique,
so we should change one of them.
Which one we change is up to you, but how
are we going to find out which locus tags
are already in use?
To do that, I'm going to take another look
at a report from the submission reports menu
called the flat file summary.
This is a view that represents all of the
flat files from all of the sequences in your
submission, displaying the unique lines and
counting how many times they appear.
This was originally derived from the idea
of using the UNIX commands sort, uniq, count
on the flat file output.
The report is divided into the sections that
appear on the flat file.
Note that this is a draft WGS submission and
it is not fully annotated.
If it was a larger sequence that it had more
annotation, it would take a little longer
to generate the summary.
We are going to move on and we are going to
look at the features.
Here we can see a list of all the qualifiers
that appear on any feature in our submission,
and we also see a list of the different kinds
of features that appear in our submission.
I am going to click on locus tag, and I'm
going to see that there are 4 items with locus
tag tst_0001 and 2 with 0002.
It tells me that these are where we have a
duplicate, and also that my next available
value is 0003.
So I'm going to click here, tst_ooo1, and
now I have a list of all of the features wear
that locus tag appears.
You may have noticed that the list includes
both the coding regions and the genes.
This is because in the flat file, the coding
region inherits the qualifiers of the gene
in which it is associated, even though the
locus tag and other qualifiers are actually
stored on the Gene feature.
It is possible to put Gene qualifiers directly
onto your coding regions and other features
, which will override what was inherited from
the Gene , but this is unnecessary.
It may be confusing for you.
You will not be able to update the gene by
editing the other feature.
So, like the submitter report and the validator,
we can launch the editor for the Gene feature
by double-clicking on the item in the submitter
report, or by double-clicking on the feature
here.
I'm going to click on this second Gene and
I'm going to double-click on it.
I am launching the editor and I'm going to
go fix the locus tag to 3.
I will click on okay.
I am going to refresh my flat file summary,
and I will look at my locus tags.
Now I can see that I have 2 for 0001, 2 for
0002, and 2 for 0003.
We will dismiss this now and I will refresh
my submitter report, and I see that the duplicate
locus tax report is gone.
All right.
There is one other thing I want to show you
today, which is a graphical view.
So, to get there, you have two options.
You can either go to the data in your project
view and select it and then right-click and
pick open new view.
Or you can go to the view menu and click on
open new view.
It's going to be the same for both of them
from here.
I'm going to scroll down to the Sequence views
and I'm going to click on graphical sequence
view and then I will pick one of the sequences
I want to take a look at.
I can use a graphical view to look at either
the nucleotide sequences or the protein sequences,
but I'm going to pick contig0001 the nucleotide
sequence.
So, like the sequence editor, the graphical
view is a great way to see a representation
of the locations of the various features on
the sequence in relation to each other, but
it does not wrap the sequence like the sequence
editor dies, and you can zoom in and out to
see more or less at the sequence at once.
This is especially good when you have lots
of long sequence, when you have a long sequence
or lots of features.
Here I will highlight part of the sequence
by going to the ruler and highlighting it,
and then I am going to use this fifth magnifying
glass over with the tooltip that says zoom
to selection to, wow, zoom to selection.
I'm going to adjust my selection by dragging
my endpoints.
And I will zoom to selection again.
So, once you have gotten to a place or you
can see your features on the screen, you can
have your, you can hover over it with the
mouse and it will show you a tooltip that
gives you a lot of information about the underlying
feature.
The other thing you can do is you can right
click on your future and you will have edit
selected objects as one of your options, among
other things, and you can bring up the same
editing menu that we saw from the flat file,
the flat file summary, the validator tab,
and the submitter report.
So, when you are done making whatever changes
that you want to make with your submission,
there are two ways that you can save your
work.
Now, the two best options are either to use
this lovely little finish button on the submission
wizard, or you can use the submission, save
submission file menu item.
You could also do this, which I do not recommend.
You could go here to, you could click here,
go to file, export data, pick ASN, select
the Seq submit, and then click finish and
it will save your file for you.
However you will notice that that was a bunch
more steps than you probably want to remember
or use.
However, you may want to use export data if
you wanted to save this in other formats like
the flat file or fast a.
So.
That is it for my talk for today.
I would like to take questions now.
Peter, what have we gotten the questions?
We have a few questions.
Did you want to run that last poll?
Yes, let's run that last poll.
Let's do that and then we have a couple of
questions you can address.
Sure.
So, the question is, have you submitted nucleotide
sequences to GenBank before?
Okay, I will go ahead and close the pool and
share the results.
You should be seeing the results now.
It looks like about a third of you submit
a lot of sequences, and overall, 50% of you
do submit.
Others are maybe going to submit soon, and
some have not done so at all.
I will read you a few questions, Colleen.
So, one of the first ones is about tbl2asn,
I think it is worth mentioning to everybody,
so that is going to continue to be supported,
correct?
Yes Tbl2ASN will be supported.
We will be coming out with new versions of
that, and improving it.
We are actively maintaining that.
Thank you.
The other thing in the same question, somebody
reports that Genome Workbench does not run
on MacOS high Sierra.
I don't know if we are aware of that or if
that is a bug report.
Are you of aware of any problems with that
operating system?
I am not, but, if they can make a bug report
that would be great and we will take a look
at that.
We can take a look at that.
Okay, another question has to do with the
translation table.
How does that work?
Is that based on the taxonomy when you are
running your submission?
That's right.
It is based on the taxonomy.
So, the coding region is going to be set to
a default.
For this record, I am looking at E. coli.
When I look at this, this genetic code was
set to bacterial, archaeal, and plant plastid.
You can override that for an individual coding
region, which, but typically it will use whatever
translation table came in with your organism.
Right.
And if you selected one of the organelles
submissions it would adjust for that as well.
Also, I have just been told, on a separate
channel, that we don't have high Sierra at
NCBI.
It is considered obsolete.
Apple no longer supports it.
Okay.
So, maybe that is something we need to make
clear on our webpages.
Right.
So, we don't, we don't have anything to test
it with.
Okay.
All right.
Next question?
A couple of sort of, you know, nitty-gritty
questions about, you know, when you are doing
submissions.
How does one assert that a three prime partial
gene on one contig and five prime partial
on another contig share a locus tag, that
is the same gene but with a sequence gap.
Can you do that?
Karen?
Yes, you can do that.
What we have been suggesting people do, one
of the things that we did not go into in this
webinar is that the coding regions, the proteins
also have to have a protein I.D., and the
protein IDs have to be unique, and generally
we recommend that you use a locus tag for
your protein I.D.
In this case, in this question where you have
a split gene, it is sort of a hack, but what
we have been recommending is that, that for
the genome, one contig, will be locus tag
... A, and the other one will be the same
beginning string, but will be B. And then
the protein IDs can also be A and B. That
keeps everything unique, and, you know, we
have people, you know, it is a split gene,
and the other part is over here on this contig.
That is what we recommend for that situation.
Another possibility is, because we accept
gapped sequences as the submission, that they
would actually be on the same sequence, and
the gene would span the gap.
Anyway, I don't want to get into the details
of all that, but that is another option, that
you give us the scaffold as the submission,
and then annotate that later.
Thanks, Karen.
There is another one about mitigating this
error, this missing xref gene error for the
miscellaneous feature.
Is that something common and easy to resolve?
Let me see if I can find that.
I'm going to go to report reports and validation
reports.
Is that one of the ones we saw here?
No.
Karen you go ahead.
My guess is there is a misc feature in the
input file but there is no corresponding gene,
but on the misc feature you have a Gene qualifier.
So when you input it you said I have a misc
feature that belongs to this gene but you
didn't have a Gene in dot cdl file.
It is really hard to guess what these things
are without actually seeing the data, but
that is my guess.
Yeah, I imagine so.
So, another thing sort of related to that
is making a bug report to NCBI.
You should be able to always write to us at
the helpdesk, and that address is info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
. There is also a link on the pages that allow
you to write to the helpdesk.
Colleen, you had a slide with some links at
the and.
You want to share that one with them, to show
some information, that way you can get more
help and documentation and things like that.
You are also going to acknowledge some people,
I think.
I just had a list of people that I would like
to thank for both developing Genome Workbench
and producing this presentation.
So they all worked on the Genome Workbench
development team . Andrea Asztalos and Igor
Filippov and Andrei Shkeda and Anatoliy Kuzetsov
all worked on the Genome Workbench development
team.
Jonathan Kans worked extensively on Sequin.
Linda Frisse is one of our indexers who provided
us with a lot of testing and advice.
And Michael Baxter, another indexer who provided
us with a lot of feedback, testing and advice.
A lot of other people just helped out with
administrative things.
Ravinder and Sanjida and Peter and Ran all
helped out with putting this presentation
together.
You can see, all of the links for where you
can get updates and ask for help.
This will be in your PowerPoint deck that
is one of the handouts for this talk.
Great.
I also just want to make a plug for our blog,
which is NCBI insights.
That is the primary place to go if you want
to see updates about things that are going
on at NCBI.
It is a good place to go to see what is new
and some of the features that we have added
to things.
Let's take a quick look to see if there any
other questions that we have in here.
One more about the miscellaneous feature,
is a Gene necessary to have a misc feature?
You already answered this one.
Generally this does not have a Gene feature.
Okay.
Well, I think that is it for today, everybody.
If there are any questions that we missed
in the questions pod, we will break them up
and put them in a document that will be available
in that directory that we had at the beginning
of the slides.
I think that is it everybody.
Thank you very much for coming.
We will talk to you later.